نذهب الان الى تطورات في الضفه الغربيه
حيث قال مراسلنا ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي دفعت بتعزيزات اضافيه لمخيم
طولكرم مع استمرار العمليه العسكريه هناك
لما يزيد عن 27 ساعه واضاف ان قوات
الاحتلال نفذت خلال العمليه حمله مداهمات
واسعه لمنازل المواطنين واعتقلت ما يزيد
عن 100 شخص من المخيم ونقلتهم لمركز تحقيق
ميداني وقد جاء ذلك بالتزامن مع اقتحام
قوات الاحتلال مخيم نور شمس بجرافات وعدد
من الاليات
العسكريه للمزيد معنا من مخيمه الكرم
مراسل الجزيره ليث جعار ليث نقترب معك
اكثر مما يجري داخل
المخيم في خضم هذه العمليه العسكريه
المستمره الان منذ اكثر من 27
ساعه
نعم تتواصل العمليه العسكريه لجيش
الاحتلال في مخيم طول كرم وسط الحصار
الواسع الذي يطبقه الاحتلال على كافه
ارجاء مخيم طول كرم حتى هذه اللحظه نتحدث
عن قرابه او ما يزيد عن 27 ساعه اي
باشر العمليه العسكريه لوصولها على ما
يقارب 30 ساعه عسك 30 ساعه متواصله
للعمليه العسكريه جيش الاحتلال يواصل
اغلاق كافه المداخل في مخيم طول كرم وسط
الاشتباكات وال والانفجارات التي لا تزال
متواصله بين الفينه والاخرى قوات الاحتلال
بدات قبل قليل
بتفجير منزل داخل المخيم وا يعني هذا
المنزل يعود لاحد الاسرى الذين تم
اعتقالهم قبل ايام فقط من مخيم طول كرم
اثناء عمليه عسكريه لجيش الاحتلال قوات
الاحتلال لا تزال والجنود الراجلين لا
يزالون يقتحمون المنازل واحدا تلو الاخر
بعض هذه المنازل قام بتدمير البنى التحتيه
بها وبعض الجدران سواء الداخليه او
الخارجيه والبعض الاخر من هذه المنازل نكل
بالمواطنين حاله مخيم طول كرم وكما يرى
مراقبون انها
حقيقه اصبحت شبه يعني منطقه منكوبه ني
لمنع دخول وخروج
المواطنين الطعام والغذاء منذ
ساعات اول امس حتى هذه اللحظه لا يزال
متواصل ومنع لدخول اي شيء الى المخيم
بالرغم من ذلك قوات الاحتلال لا تزال
تعتقل وتستمر في عمليات الاعتقال لما يزيد
عن 100 فلسطيني من داخل هذا المخيم هذا
الشارع ولك ان
تتخيلي المنطقه الحيويه لمخيم طول كرم
مدمره بشبه كامل للبن التحتيه لبعض
المنشات التجاريه والمحال التجاريه في هذه
المنطقه ايضا في منطقه المربعه الى الشرق
من المخيم حيث قام الاحتلال وعبر جرافات
الدي 9 بتدمير البنى التحتيه
والمنشات وبعض المنازل وجدران هذه المنازل
قوات الاحتلال في هذه الصوره لربما نشاهد
عدد من الجنود الراجلين
الذين يقتحمون منزلا تلو الاخر ينفذون
اعمال المداهمه والتحقيق الميداني
والتفتيش لعدد كبير من المنازل نتحدث حتى
هذه اللحظه عن خمسه شهداء
وايضا ما يزيد عن 15 اصابه من بينها
اصابات بالرصاص الحي ناتجه والبعض الاخر
ناتجه عن الاعتداء وفي هذه اللحظات وصلنا
من مصدر في مخيم نور شمس ايضا ان هناك اصا
اصابه في منطقه المسلخ نتيجه لاستمرار
الاقتحام المتواصل ايضا لمخيم نور شمس
بالتزامن مع العمليه العسكريه لجيش
الاحتلال على مخيم طول كرم لما يزيد او
لما يقارب ال 30 ساعه حتى هذه اللحظه مخيم
نور شمس دفع الاحتلال بجرافات دي 9
وجرافات عاديه الى منطقه حي المنشيه قاموا
باعمال التجريف والتخريب للبنى التحتيه
وسط انفجارات واشتباكات متوا صله في داخل
منطقه المنشيه تحديدا ومن ثم عادت بعض هذه
الاليات العسكريه الى هنا الى مخيم طول
كرم حيث لا تزال العمليه العسكريه واطباق
الخناق متواصل لا طعام لا حليب للاطفال
ولا حتى الامور الانسانيه يمكن لها ان
تدخل هنا الى مخيم طول كرم على غرار ما
يحدث ايضا في قطاع غزه وفي باقي مدن الضفا
الغربيه المحتله ش ل جعار من مخيم طول كرم
شكرا جزيلا لك d